[Musique]
bienvenue dans la grande interview notre
invité aujourd'hui michèle audette femme
politique canadienne engagée dans la
défense des droits des femmes
autochtones commissaire en 2019 de l'
enquête nationale sur les femmes
autochtones aient disparues et
assassinées et conseillère principale à
la réconciliation à l'université laval
bonjour me sèye michèle audette vous
nous répondez depuis québec
merci d'être parmi nous merci oui ou
alors michèle audette pendant trois ans
à titre de commissaire de l'enquêté
nationale sur les femmes et les filles
autochtones disparues et assassinées
vous avez écouté
de nombreux témoignages de familles
autochtones des familles dont des
membres avaient disparu et qu'ils n'ont
pas été aidés ou écouté par les
autorités cette enquête elle fait suite
à un rapport du comité à vérité et
réconciliation on y apprend que plus de
cent cinquante mille enfants amérindiens
métis et inuits ont été envoyés de force
pendant des décennies dans des
pensionnats gérées par l'église
catholique
selon le comité vérité et réconciliation
4000 enfants auraient trouvé la mort
dans ces établissements encore ouverts
jusque dans les années 90 alors michèle
audette quel était le but de ces
pensionnats c'est une politique
d'assimilation en vertu d'une culture
malheureusement qui a perduré pendant
trop longtemps qu'on va déterminer la
com commission d' enquête sur les femmes
et filles autochtones d'une violence
coloniale dont l'objectif était de faire
en sorte que nous devenions de bons
canadiens en bonne et due forme alors
nous déposséder de nos trois nos
relations de territoire et surtout de
notre identité culturelle et en quelques
mots je l ai dié dans l'enfant ces
pensionnats il était à gérer par
l'église catholique
comment était-il géré et financé bain
une certaine époque au québec jusqu'en
en effet c'est les communautés
religieuses
qui vont administrer gérer et gouverner
c'est le pensionnat travers le canada
mais ici au québec aussi et par lui par
la suite le québec va devenir
responsable ou vont prendre sa
responsabilité en matière d'éducation et
de santé et bien d'autres choses qui
fait que aujourd'hui 1996 on vous
connaît les effets ou pardon reconnaître
les écoles résidentielles
mes parents sont allés du côté de ma
mère dans les écoles résidentielles
on nous apprenait à de bonnes femmes
ménagères il n'aura collège histoire du
range la philosophie l'histoire ou
apprendre à lire et à écrire
et chez nous sommes autochtone à comment
être menuisier ou attentats quelqu'un
qui va travailler là au sein d'une usine
où quelque quelque chose comme ça et
sans vous vous cachez de plessé wismes
sexuelle violence puisque le gic mentale
et spirituelle
alors justement mais celle odette on
parle de 150 mille enfants donc
amérindiens métis et inuits qui ont été
envoyés dans ces pensionnats
comment ça s'est passé à quel âge les
enfants ils étaient envoyés combien de
temps il reste et il est à quoi
concrètement ressembler leur vie dans
ces pensionnats le début des de cette
politique coloniale on a mis sur pied
d'un prix du lait
une police montée qu'on appelait et
qu'on appelle encore aujourd'hui la
gendarmerie royale du canada donc la grc
qui existe toujours mais que plus
seulement de devenir en territoire et
prendre vie en france sans le
consentement des parents et élise
arrachés de leur territoire pour les
amis dans d'autres régions dans d'autres
provinces très très loin alors ces
enfants-là partir de 3 ans 4 1 10 à 12
ans 14 ans ont été arrachés sur une
longue longue longue période plusieurs
décennies les parents ne parlent pas le
français ou l'anglais les enfants
devenus adultes retournant communauté
complètement dépossédés de leurs repères
naturels en termes d'identité autochtone
est institué donc m'a convié mentionné
plus tôt ma propre famille du côté de ma
mère va vivre l'agression sexuelle
médiation la violence est bien les
choses comme ça et commence à celui ça
se vit très difficilement le dernier
pensionnat sur le sol canadien a fermé
ses portes en 96 comment se sont
déroulées ces fermetures et qui est à
l'initiative de ces fermetures
plusieurs personnes peu auront été à
l'initiative dans différentes régions
soit le leadership de la nation qui
habitent ce territoire là depuis
longtemps
évidemment les provinces les gouvernants
que le gouvernement fédéral pour
participer à ces fermetures là on parle
de fermeture mais on ne parle pas de
fermeture au niveau de la guérison ou
des violences multi générationnelle et
intergénérationnelle de là l'importance
de la commission vérité réconciliation
que proposait des processus de guérison
donc ceci fermeture la physique ont
existé par contre fermer une plaie c'est
donc comme un processus très vivant bien
sûr fin juin justement 182 tombes
anonymes ont été à découverte sur le
site d'un ancien pensionnat à cranbrook
en colombie britannique
elle c'est la troisième découverte de ce
type en un mois en tout depuis le mois
de mai ce sont plus de mille tombes
anonymes qui ont été découvertes dans en
colombie britannique et dans le
saskatchewan je ne sais pas si je le
prononce bien quel est l'élément
déclencheur de ces fouilles
l'élément déclencheur peut paraître
comme étant très très très récent par
contre d'un rapport de la vérité de la
commission vérité réconciliation on va
faire référence dans un chapitre complet
sur la parole la vérité des gens qui ont
malheureusement connu les pensionnaires
et les écoles résidentielles vont avoir
mentionné à certains endroits on pense
que le corps de petit enfant ou demi ou
deux cousins ou membres de famille
serait peut-être là alors ça fait une
vingtaine d'années que camelot la
première page il dit qu'on va entendre
il ya quelques temps de ça va avoir
commencé ses travaux et on va remarquer
maintenant que la vérité n'a pas été
pris en considération la technologie
avec les drom qui sont capables de voir
où sont ces ces petits êtres lumière
donc corroborer ce qui a été dit a
longtemps
alors pour vous dire comment notre voie
était beaucoup plus importante que la
technologie mais le statu quo de l'état
ont fait en sorte qu'il fallut que ça
soit quelque chose de plus moderne pour
vous croit d'autrefois sont elles
prévues ailleurs dans le pays notamment
au québec par exemple au québec des
discussions comme moi en ce moment avec
l'université laval ont réfléchi à
peut-être mettre autour d'une même table
qu'elle soit virtuel ou physique des
gens qui ont connu les pensionnats et
des gens qui ont une volonté de trouver
la vérité et d'amis pour justin aspects
techniques et technologiques et moderne
mais d'amener aussi l'aspect de
commandes doit faire ces fouilles
ab qui devons nous y faire et il parlait
de tout l'accompagnement psychosocial
qu'il soit spirituel ou santé publique
occidentale pour assurer qu on ne fait
pas juste trouver mais on va en aurait
aussi un certain parti qui a été
longtemps cachés ici au canada
l'existence vient justement de ces
enfants a disparu était pourtant connue
notamment à travers des témoignages de
nombreuses familles pourquoi est ce que
l'on découvre les corps que maintenant
ça a été difficile à l'époque parce que
bon comme comme je les mentionnaient la
technologie n'a pas été au rendez vous à
ces époques
c'est à travers le monde c'est pas juste
un fait isolé ici au canada ou à quelque
part au canada et le fait aussi que ma
parole n'a pas été considéré comme étant
une preuve parce que le droit de fait on
est obligé de voir où on s'oblige de
trois ans quelque chose pour le croire
alors que la parole était très important
maintenant on va pouvoir arrimer son
ensemble
il peut être accéléré justement les
fouilles à travers le canada
et quelle va être la suite justement en
termes d' enquête après la découverte
des corps les suites si je peux me
permettre
là je pense que beaucoup parties
prenantes qu'il faut considérer
quels seront les sud du point de vue
d'un gouvernement kenney canadiens quels
seront les issues du point de vue du
gouvernement si je prends ma région ici
du gouvernement du québec et bien sûr
quels seront les points de vue des
nations qui ont perdu des êtres chers et
comment on doit travailler ensemble pour
assurer de de sortir tous je le répète
encore ce qui a été longtemps caché
comment comment est-ce qu'ils vont être
par exemple identifier comment est ce
qu'on va pouvoir retrouver les identités
de ces enfants il est obligé au façon
qu'on peut faire évidemment l'adn ou est
un aspect important don dans ma vision
dans le rêve que j'ai eus ou dans la
façon que je vois les choses avec des
collègues faut assurer que différentes
expertises sont autour de cette grande
table pour une fois qu'on a trouvé les
corps comment peut les associer à une
famille donc
ddd l'adn bruit très très important donc
les experts dans ce domaine là mais
aussi dans l'anthropologie dans
l'histoire dans la sociologie et tout ce
tout petit expertise le moindre point
tellement fondamentale alors que c'est
pas juste on amèneront on trouve ça
merci bonjour mon nom c'est une une
relation qui va devoir être multi
excusez moi la façon de le dire avec une
multitude expertise si je peux me
permettre
comment expliquer que les témoignages
des familles à l'époque des familles qui
est témoigné de la disparition leurs
enfants on ait trouvé aucun écho ça
c'est un des chapitres dans lequel mois
comme ancien commissaire sur les femmes
et filles autochtones assassinées et
disparues
très tôt dans le rapport mentionne
oui la violence coloniale mais comment
nous comme société ou comme gouvernement
ou instituts le statu quo si ça ne me
concerne pas je nage je ne m'occupe pas
de ça et alors qu'avant c'était je ne
dois pas m'en occuper parce que je veux
assimilés ou faire disparaître ces
groupes là je pense pas que les gens
aujourd'hui se réveille pour deux je
vais faire une assignation volontaires
être forcée mais qui va être rentré dans
une culture organisationnelle au sein de
l'état au sein d'un mouvement ou d'une
société et au point où les billets
implicite vont faire en sorte que je
vais poser aussi des actions pour
continuer à agir dans un style chic ou
qui fait que c'est bon à moi de faire
ces choses là où ça me concerne pas je
ne m'implique pas mais je le dette selon
le comité vérité et réconciliation on
l'a dit 4000 enfants auraient trouvé la
mort dans ces établissements
les causes des décès les enfants sont
elles connues à ce jour certaines causes
sont connues et il si je peux me
permettre
l'ancien commissaire de cette commission
denquête monsieur sinclair pense même
qu'on peut parler de plus de 20000
peut-être lumière qui ne sont jamais
retournés chez eux
alors on dit 4000 parce qu'ils y ont eu
accès à des documents lors de leur
commission denquête et certaines causes
du décès peut peut varier un mauvaise
nutrition
on a fait les tests sur eux et sur elle
avec des détails nous une forme de
nouvelle médication dont c'est carrément
de la maltraitance sinon on va aussi
connaître de tristes de témoignages ou
des jeunes ont vu d'autres jeunes sans
vie la vie à cause de du mal de vivre
tout simplement donc on peut appeler
malheureusement suicide dans ce cas ci
alors le rapport estime que allait
décéder petite fille sont plus nombreux
quelle est l'explication selon vous
je pourrais peut-être imaginer ce qui
est encore le cas aujourd'hui
les tentatives de suicide sont très
élevés mais là malheureusement la
réussite est souvent dans ce qu'on va
découvrir dans le chemin vie de la
petite fille ou de la femme 80 à 90% va
avoir été agressée sexuellement ou
violée à plusieurs reprises donc dans le
profil de vie où l'histoire de vie de
ces personnes là nous le savons que la
communauté religieuse une ou par
plusieurs personnes vont avoir abusé de
ses enfants le sexuellement mais j'ai la
dette on va marquer une courte pause on
se retrouve dans un instant
[Musique]
bienvenue dans la grande interview si
vous nous rejoignez notre invité
aujourd'hui michèle audette femme
politique canadienne engagée dans la
défense des droits des femmes
autochtones et commissaire en 2019 de l'
enquête nationale sur les femmes
autochtones aient disparues et
assassinées et conseillère principale à
la réconciliation à l'université laval
michèle audette une commission denquête
parle de génocide culturel le chef de la
fédération et des nations autochtones
souveraine de la province de la
saskatchewan parle lui de crimes contre
l'humanité est-ce que l'on peut
effectivement employer ce terme selon
vous je vous dirais lorsqu'on va
terminer les travaux de l'enquêté
nationale sur les femmes et filles
autochtones assassiné disparu nous avons
retiré le mot culturel donc on parle ici
d'un gilet ces deux politiques
génocidaires
on ne fait pas référence seulement a
attaqué un groupe parce qu'on veut des
phares sa culture mais plutôt de parler
de plusieurs formes easydis de génocide
alors on a fait référence ou si la
définition de l'onu de que que signifie
un ou plusieurs formes de génocide
je vous dirais que ça la dérange ici au
canada que les femmes s'exprime de la
sorte alors vous comprendrez que la
stérilisation forcée qu'on fait auprès
des femmes autochtones
encore aujourd'hui le fait qu'on va
hospitalisés nos enfants sans la
présence des parents et suite à cette
hospitalisation
on sait plus du tout où ils sont c'est
arrivé ici au québec dans les années 50
60 et 70
et de là pour nous que ça va au delà de
la culture mais plutôt un crime contre
l'humanité si on ferait pas saisi au
seuil d'une dacia
le premier ministre canadien justin
trudeau a réagi sur twitter après les
découvertes des rêves des enfants selon
lille selon lui le pays va devoir tirer
les leçons de son passé envers les
premières nations victimes de
discrimination et d'injustice systémique
pour autant pas de reconnaissance de
gêne aussi du côté du gouvernement
canadien est ce qu'il refuse ce terme
aujourd'hui je ne croyais pas je ne
croirai pas part
le 3 juin 2019 lorsque nous avons remis
le rapport
et c'est un rapport qui va est
historique car chaque gouvernement donc
14 enquêtes simultanée où on remet à
tous les gouvernements parce qu'ils ont
signé des décrets en conseil des ordres
d'un conseil qui nous donne l'autorité
comme des juges
et comme enquêteur de sortir des
archives et avec les archives nous avons
bâti ses preuves
où on mentionne politique génocidaire ou
où tant de génocide ici au canada et il
n'a pas dit qu'il refusait mais plutôt
reconnu toutes les conclusions et les
appels à la justice du rapport de
l'emploi et qu'elle justement quelles
actions ont été entreprises par le
gouvernement canadien
si on parle d'action faut être conscient
il consciente que nous avons été frappés
vous nous et tout le monde à travers la
planète par une pandémie
donc on parle de la commune 19 qui va
ralentir les travaux parce que nos
partenaires dans le rapport l'emploi
donne nous demandons à tous les
gouvernements du canada de travailler de
concert en co construction pour
appliquer nous d'honorer les appels à la
justice
et ces mêmes partenaires l'or était en
train de sauver des vies sur le terrain
pendant cette pandémie
aujourd'hui on va voir un budget que moi
depuis mes 20 quelques dernières années
en politique communautaire mme
canadienne de voir un budget avec
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de mesure et
d'argent pour appliquer et honorer les
appels à la justice
je dois vous dire que ce sont des
actions importantes
ensuite 2 pour terminer parce qu'il y en
a beaucoup on parle de transparence de
reddition de compte là donc on va voir
dans un plan d'action qui a été
construit avec les familles des
survivants et survivante
à l'intérieur de l'appareil proposé les
structures de reddition compte pour moi
ça c'est une très grande victoire comme
membre comme femme même six survivants
et témoins de plusieurs formes de
violence et en plus commissaire de cette
grande commission
c'est enfin là un pas dans lequel je
peux dire oui
le gouvernement provincial et fédéral
ont pris des appels qu'on a nommé est
proposée de façon sérieuse c'est pas ces
pensionnats dont nous parlons étaient
gérées par l'église dans l'église
catholique
quelle est la relation qu'elle était sa
réaction aujourd'hui l'église où les
communautés religieuses il ya beaucoup
de recours collectif en ce moment
pendant la quête nationale
on va avoir eu des témoignages dans la
région d'où je viens de she's in touch
ou un prêt devons avoir abusé pendant
longtemps pendant 40 ans plusieurs
générations de membres hommes femmes
aînés et jeunes
alors on peut attirer ce à travers le
reste du québec et du canada
la relation est amour haine je vous
dirais et il leur silence en ce moment
sur la découverte des petits êtres
lumière les enfants les jeunes leur
silence je voudrais qu'il y à grand
mécontentement mais il ya aussi un appel
au calme de la porte de certains leaders
qu'ils disent et ils ont contribué à
cette grande souffrance mais nous ne
devons pas donner la même médecine en
termes de violence envers ces individus
ou envers cette communauté
mais nous avons le droit d'être très en
colère et de leur dire nous exigeons oui
des excuses mais réparations parce que
justement il ya eu de nombreuses églises
qui ont été a brûlé notamment à alberta
et eu des statuts qui ont été
déboulonnées aussi est-ce que c'est des
actions vous que vous que vous soutenez
brûlé non pour avoir moi même vécu c'est
comme perdre d'une maison après un pull
je veux même pas ça à des gens que je je
je je
j'aurais de la difficulté à côtoyer
parce qu'ils sont sont pas dans une
violence ou dans un espace qui manque de
respect non on ne peut pas et on ne doit
pas faire ce genre d'action parce qu'on
veut promouvoir la non violence on veut
promouvoir pour ma part
la cohabitation est le mieux vivre
ensemble mais de déboulonner une statue
ça peut être une façon s'cusez mon bon
anglicismes speedman une déclaration
pour dire vous m'avez arraché pendant
150 ans et plus
alors si je pose cette action-là compte
cette statue c'est une façon de vous
dire comment j'ai de la colère mais en
même temps est-ce que ça va guérir tout
ce qui s'est passé de façon et depuis
très très longtemps je ne croirais pas
je pense que la pédagogie doit être
beaucoup plus puissant plus importantes
sur cette personne là je ne peux plus la
voir comme statut mais voici les raisons
pourquoi est maintenant dans mon
processus de guérison avec la personne
qui est québécoise ou canadienne et de
l'ami disputé ici au québec qu est ce qu
on pourrait proposer ensemble pour
parler de connaître l'histoire qui a été
caché
et comment pourrait coup construire une
meilleure relation michel z pour revenir
sur l'église est ce que par exemple il
faudrait que le vrai que le pape
s'excuse je demande pardon selon vous
plus que ça pour ma part le plus que ça
le pack comprend que dans ma propre
famille aussi où la communauté
catholique
la communauté va pouvoir avoir un
certain respect oui peut s'excuser mais
je m'attendrais à beaucoup plus que des
excuses je m'attendrais à ses excuses
apporte aussi un processus dans lequel
vous et moi on va s'entendre ce comment
vous la voyez votre guérison
comment vous la voyez votre prise de
contrôle sur votre vie sur votre
identité sur votre que dieu que je vous
ai arraché pendant 500 ans
alors comment faire ce des studios les
ensembles pour moi c'est peut-être rêver
mais je ne saurais vie c'est comme ça je
le verrai et justement est ce que
l'église s'est engagée par exemple a
collaboré à fournir certains dossiers à
fournir certaines archives par exemple
qui pourrait aider dans l'identification
des enfants
je vous pourrez pas vous répondre en ce
moment avec ce qui se passe mais je
pourrais vous dire que dans d'autres
situations dans lequel les trois
commissaires de vérité et réconciliation
on veut juste rendre jusqu'en cour
fédérale pour la cour canadienne notre
fédéral pour avoir accès à des documents
alors que nous les quatre commissaires
de la mfa daf femmes et filles
autochtones assassiné disparu nous
avions un pouvoir que jamais été
octroyée aucun commissaire autochtone le
pouvoir de contrainte donc d'exiger les
documents et si on n'avions pas les
documents de la police pouvait aller
chercher en notre nom et je vous dirais
que eu beaucoup beaucoup difficultés
pour avoir toutes ces informations là du
côté de d'informations sur comment sont
morts les enfants
de quoi sont ils ces enfants là les
causes et circonstances et je vois
aujourd'hui les familles qui ont des
recours collectifs contre la communauté
religieuse qui va par des individus
abusé physiquement et sexuellement sur
plusieurs personnes et plusieurs
générations vont tout faire pour
contester des recours collectifs
ça démontre un peu que je pense que la
relation pour trouver les vérités et
associer les noms et tout ça va être
très difficile avec les communautés
religieuses
mais c'est la tête de ce rapport du
comité vérité et réconciliation sur les
pensionnats est née une autre enquête
dont vous avez été commissaire elle
porte sur les femmes et les filles
autochtones disparues et assassinées le
rapport final de cette enquête a été
déposée en 2019 quels étaient les
conclusions de cette enquête les
conclusions une violence coloniale qui
perdure le fait que la coupe un des
gouverneurs
comment va avoir cette façon de faire
qu'on appelle le stand jco voit un
pouvoir ne prendrait pas en
considération les expertises des femmes
et des familles mais toujours proposer
les approches sans nous mettre au coeur
de ces réflexions là et bien sûr on
parle de violence coloniale et de
génocide
on parle de génocide et des preuves
les analyses juridiques et pourquoi nous
en sommes rendus là nous allons aussi
proposer deux cent cinquante et une
proposition qu'on appelle des appels à
la justice et pour terminer je vous
dirais avec des lunettes de droit
international droit canadien droit
autochtone et droits de femmes
autochtones ils étape pour nous que ce
ne sont plus des recommandations mais
plutôt des impératifs jury t vous parlez
de violon ce colonel c'est c'est quelque
chose qui s'inscrit dans le quotidien
des populations autochtones
c'est exact c'est exact encore
aujourd'hui au moment où je vous parle
le 20 juillet peu je vais avoir 50 ans
je suis grand mère de deux petites
filles baird 55 sont adultes et
adolescents bien sûr mais légalement la
loi me considère encore avec la loi sur
les indiens comme une mineure dans
toutes les personnes qui sont issus de
la lho sous la loi sur les indiens d'une
nation attaché à ça nous sommes
malheureusement encore considérés comme
des mineurs alors pour moi c'est très
près de paternalisme colonial et dans la
façon qu'on va proposer les projets de
loi ou des programmes au sein de
notation très rangeront avoir eu un
droit de parole ou une participation
pleine et entière pour assurer que ce
qu'on propose les bamboo ma génération
d'aujourd'hui les sept prochaines
générations à venir donc c'est juste
pour vous donner quelques exemples que
malheureusement sa merci mais je veux
être juste à dire question qui est la
femme en photo derrière vous ben hammam
un merci merci beaucoup d'avoir
participé à cette grande interview
c'est la fin de cette émission merci
de l'avoir suivi une grande interview
que vous pourrez retrouver sur notre
site internet
rt france point est tv à bientôt sur rt
france
[Musique]